the sheer magnitude of this catastrophe
is becoming clear as water continues to
Surge through the breached wall of the
collapsed Dam towards her son less than
50 miles away homes have been submerged
many just swept away and once fertile
agricultural grounds now a soggy
Wasteland it has triggered an
environmental catastrophe endangering
drinking water and an entire ecosystem
and a humanitarian crisis forcing the
evacuation of thousands
even as War continued to rage around
them for the people of her son who
endured months of Russian fire only to
be chased from their homes by Rising
water it is too much